three of four already from downtown the
rockets are of
three not shy at all westbrook right
wing harden open three in the air and he
gets the three points right back
one on one of the corner pulls back
fires up a three off the inbounds and it
goes and the game is now tied at 15
as james harden rivers tries to turn the
corner cannot brings it back out between
the circles to harden on pourier oh he
loves
playing with big men in space he'll pull
back he'll shoot and he will bury the
three that's
13 for 13. drives finishes
and now he has a hot hand has proved
that he absolutely belongs in the
association been a terrific addition to
the rockets
hard on the wing doubled pulls back
shoots for three bottom
of the net he's a big-time player
and he's a big-time worker that's like
no space at all
and eric gord good inside positioning on
poirier ripped the rebound from him
westbrook at the corner to harden
catches fire scores
incredible stuff there were a lot of
bodies in between russ and macklemore
quick inbounds hard
quarter three that's his sixth three
of the first half
[Applause]
half seconds different game shot clock
as we wind it down in this first half
hard on water maker pull back three
uh-oh feeling it
oh my goodness james hard on fire hits
again from downtown from downtown that
one
the appropriate heat check for a guy who
was flaming hot
here in this game